he's Tom Curren back here on the Rich
Eisen show host the quick slant podcast
and the beat reporter and NFL insider
for NBC Sports Boston - Tommy commendeth
what's going on rich what are the
Patriots what are they up to Tom what
was it yesterday all about best you can
tell best I can tell is any draft
collateral there our entire roster
except at least our depth chart rich is
kind of falling into needing a
renovation okay obviously you've got a
team who's gone to three Super Bowls in
four years one two of them is doing
pretty well but when you look at the
roster and look at the last two drafts
they only had three players drafted last
year make the team the previous year
they didn't have a first-round pick
their first pick was Cyrus Jones has
been a little bit of a disappointment so
they need to renovate so in grabbing
those picks and now having to
first-rounders the theory is that they
might go up I don't know if so
necessarily go up rich they might need
to spend all those picks to help
renovate the roster and in terms of
Brandon cooks he was useful in 2017 a
good player but they sent the 31st
overall to the 32nd overall pick to New
Orleans for him and they turned it into
the 23rd a year later and they just this
wasn't a great fit here not a horrible
player by any stretch - one of the
spurts the guy but just one the great
fit well what it all comes down to it I
mean take to get a guy in for a year and
almost won the Super Bowl with them and
trade that pick and improve it the
following year I mean that's a that's a
nice nice roster maneuver out of
Belichick but the question is is is
staying put for who I mean he must have
somebody identified to stay put Tom what
do you think that he's looking at thinks
that he can get at 23 and 31 or move
around and move up what is the plan at
least going in if they do stay put here
when they talk about looking of what
they're going to get they just stack so
you Belichick has been and NICUs area as
well you can't predict what the 22 teams
ahead of you are going to do when you're
a 23 so you need a handful of players if
you would target if it drop to that
level so it could be positional or it
could be the best player out
but could be tight-end could be a
quarterback but you're gonna go through
those first five or six guys who are at
the top pretty quickly and they'll be
gone by 15 if he wants to move up for a
backup quarterback I don't know if that
makes a hell of a lot of sense
not a backup but a guy who's a projected
started down the road I don't think it
makes sense to do when you have other
needs on the team that are immediate sit
there wait for somebody else as you
difficult a Kyle Willetta but
defensively they need speed in my
estimation rich so let's let's go off
the rails a little bit then what's more
what's more possible that these two
first rounders are used to get Odell
Beckham or these two first rounders and
others are used as capital go up and get
somebody to replace Brady one day more
likely but still not likely at all would
be to use the two to get up and get a
quarterback I think Belichick over the
course of time he once told me in 2001
they had drafted Seymour and I said to
him you know what why did you do that
because at that time you know the
thought was David Terrell was there and
Bledsoe could throw downfield to him and
Brady hadn't emerged you know even at
that point when the draft had come
embellished accessory goes who's the
best wide receiver rookie wide receiver
this year you know it's Chris Chambers
he's a second-round pick from wherever
the hell Wisconsin or something who was
with the Dolphins because you don't need
to go up into the top ten to take a wide
receiver so he certainly wouldn't spend
two firsts in my estimation to go and
get Odell Beckham who's looking for more
money he'd sit tight and get the excuse
me get the quarterback see if he chose
that was the route mm-hmm Tom Curren of
NBC Sports Boston here okay so since
since the end of the since we last spoke
after the Super Bowl the Patriots have
watched Danny Amendola leave with
Gronkowski giving him a social media
send-off of saying be happy be free he's
talking about not maybe coming back
solder is now a giant and now
Cook's is a ram how is Brady what is he
thinking right now Tom in Dion Lewis is
elsewhere as well correct he's a tiger
you got a huge outflow of offensive
talent
what's Brady thinking I think honestly
from my contacts and sources he's
thinking about just getting his brain in
order with his family and trying to
recalibrate and figure out exactly what
he wants to do going forward I don't
think that he's gonna get caught up with
the ins and outs in the roster
machinations he never really has he
hasn't had that GM level of input here
with the Patriots over the course of
time which is you know interesting when
you think of the other players who have
around the NFL as quarterbacks so I
don't think he's losing his mind about
it I do imagine though when you talk
about dates older the Patriots have a
tendency to put a lot on Brady as you
know over the years and the buck ends up
stopping with him even if the roster
decisions are made elsewhere so this guy
takes less money than virtually every
decent quarterback in the league and
he's better than them and more falls on
his plate to try and clean up the talent
or lack of talent we're developing
talent issues that the team has
elsewhere so I think that's where some
of this notion of under appreciation is
his wife's alluded to at the end of Tom
versus time might enter into it as well
as you know just the ability to think of
his own brand and future going forward
as a 40 year old so look here's the
narrative right know what the Patriots
are Tom I mean let's be honest here I
mean the whole situation it's difficult
to get a wrap on that it could just be
it just could be Belichick is
stockpiling Talent because he knows that
uh that he's gonna be there for quite
some time before he may or may not hand
the reins off to McDaniels who jilted
the Colts may it because he may or may
not have been told that he's the next
guy and then Brady sitting there who and
he he may or may not be thinking of
stepping away and Gronk may or may not
be thinking about stepping away
and how what what is the current state
of Gronkowski right now Tom as you can
tell the best I can tell is he'll play
in 2018 and the fact that the Patriots
traded away Brandon cooks as Adam
Schefter and I trust Adams reporting
implicitly he's generally right on with
the Patriots and he says that now this
means the Quran Kowski is not going to
be traded well it's Gronkowski gonna
play eventually I think he's gonna you
know put his shirt back on turn his hat
around forward and come back and play
football do I think that all of this
stuff his offseason feeling his oats and
and stringing things out and sending
some tweeting the team I've gone over
big no they absolutely haven't but I
don't think that there's a lot of
recourse to the team I also will be very
intrigued to see whether or not he gets
the same kind of incentive Laden
contract that he did last year because
if you're Belichick and you have kids
jumping up and down upstairs make it a
whole crapload of noise and all the
other kids sitting at the dinner table
behaving themselves
do you go upstairs and reward the kid
who's making all the noise upstairs just
to convince him to come down to the
table and eat dinner I mean that's
really I mean if that sends a bad
message for the quote-unquote culture I
think so that there's a lot going on
like you said man you're exactly right
that's why it's hard to stay on one path
with this team and just converse in one
small silo so then in terms of the known
known the the known unknowns if you will
last one for you here tom is there's no
doubt with the quarterback group as deep
as it is and the Patriots have so much
flexibility to move wherever the hell
they want on a draft board right now
that that Belichick and the rest of the
group have to be identifying somebody
saying if this guy's available at the
right spot we're gonna take him who's
that quarterback I'd say it's the kid
from Richmond Kyle Lelaina and only
because he checks all those weird
intangible blocks I love that I know
multi-year captain at Richmond played on
to multiple us as the coordinators
father was a quarterback at Navy so was
this great
uncle or something at Navis so all of
these things contribute to that plus
he's a little bit below the radar the
leadership stuff but you know that ends
up being one of those situations where
all the breadcrumbs are there so we go
to Kyle or Letta and then they in turn
go yeah okay yeah we just saw Johnny
Manziel haha surprise
do you think that's possible I don't
think it's impossible that this
basically could this entire conversation
and was brought to you by is it possible
I don't think it's impossible to play
I'm trying to remember a couple years
ago they had that Patriots draft
scouting report on Johnny Manziel 'dick
somehow got beat like just revisit that
just take another look at it rich and
look at it because it does not pan him
by any stretch of the imagination it
does not pan his into a thing go back do
it like this Patriots policy meeting
them in the hallway outside of it though
it was open on my go Tom you're not
allowed to go in now you're out you're
out of the Hall of Fame you're finished
all right buddy you got his downtown at
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience